in the heart of Cambridge is an AI
startup like no other
it's called audio analytic and you can
think of it as a type of Shazam for
real-world sounds we use artificial
intelligence to allow smart home devices
to recognize a whole range of different
signs that happen inside your houses
it can make your house a bit secure by
detecting glass windows being broken and
then turning your lights and scareware
in the Bergerac should take an active
protection of you know things you care
about so what do we have here what what
is those um so we've got a couple of
devices that make the sounds that this
detects smoke along see it's detected
smoke alarm on there nobody's at home so
it's now sending a iMessage another
sound
um this is glass break yeah that that
off you can see it says window broken
yeah
what is the science behind all of us we
have to do a whole bunch of innovation
in terms of understanding sounds how to
detect them and to have a machine
understand them even if we take a simple
sound like a smoke alarm that's beep
we'll never got two of them going beep
at different times with a whole bunch of
background noise going on that's a big a
lie problem to solve computers have to
be trained to distinguish one sound from
another and to learn the unique
signature of say glass breaking audio
analytic trains its software by
presenting it with examples of a
particular noise of course no two
breaking windows sound exactly alike so
these guys get to relieve stress by
breaking a lot of glass how many windows
have you had to break windows we
literally filled warehouses for it on
months on end different sizes different
thicknesses different type of glass
how many smoke alarms smoke alarms we
literally bought all smoke alarms you
can find on the market place and then
indexed all those that was a huge
undertaking logistically the software
can also recognize the sound of a baby
crying hi Daisy
oh hi and as luck would have it we found
a cute hungry baby on which to
experiment so you can see on the screen
is detecting the baby cry
audio analytics software already ships
inside a number of smart home products
and the company plans on adding many
more sounds oh my god but for now it's
the perfect technology to discover when
an angry baby has thrown a smoke alarm
through a window I'm sorry we have to do
that no she was very sweet well done the
first TV show
Oh